Uh, which phone do you find the hardest to follow yourself?
Probably the hardest one is to tell the truth, or at least not to lie.
Why is it a constant challenge,
but because it's easy to use your speech in a way that pays off in the short
term, and it's difficult to contend with the conflict. That's inevitable.
If you try to do things in a straightforward manner,
because that produces short-term conflict, it produces long-term peace,
which is a huge advantage,
but it's very tempting in the short term to
circumvent the problem and pretend that it's not there.
Do you sometimes avoid telling the truth just to be kind?
Um, I try to be as kind as possible, but no.
Good.
I'm tempted to,
because I'm fundamentally an agreeable person surprisingly enough,
but I'm convinced that it's better to face things when they need
to be faced and to get to the bottom of things. Even though that's, it's been,
of course you have to be constituted in that manner. If you're going to be,
uh, an useful psychotherapist, because you can't let things go,
they have to be dealt with just like they have to be dealt with. If,
if you're a medical professional, it's unpleasant to sit,
tell someone that they have an illness,
it hurts their feelings and it upsets them. But if you don't deal with it,
then perhaps they die and psychological issues can be of the same
significance.
You talk, you talk sometimes about weak men.
Uh, why are weak men such a problem?
Well, weak people are a problem in general. And I don't mean physically weak.
I mean,
cowardly let's say and deceitful because I'm thinking it more in terms of moral
weakness. Well, there's a variety of reasons is first of all,
if you can't support your own weight,
let's say then someone else has to do it and that's not good.
And then if you don't make your pathway,
if you don't pick a forthright and useful and noble pathway through life,
then you'll become bitter and too hurt by the
tragedy of existence.
And then you tend to seek your revenge wherever you can get it.
And that's not good. So it's a, it's a mistake on all fronts.
It's not good for you. It's not good for your family.
It's not good for the community. Um,
it's certainly not a good medium to long-term strategy because life is very,
very difficult and you have to be prepared for that.
And I had to
watch her the other night.
He was at my lecture in Oslo and he wrote me a letter. He was a 17 year old boy.
And he said that he, that my work had been very helpful to him. His father died.
Suddenly about six months before,
and he found his dad when he was dying and was very,
very shocked and horrified and hurt by what had happened.
And I had recommended on my YouTube lectures,
that one thing you could aim for was to be the strongest
person at your father's funeral.
And so that's what he did.
And he helped his mom and he wrote a 200 word eulogy and got through it.
And so good for him that strength and necessary.
It's a terrible thing that happened,
but he did everything he could not to make it any worse than it had to be the
DNA.
I see that showing weakness can be a strength too.
Not weakness, vulnerability. And that's,
that's a whole different thing to admit, to, uh,
to admit to the fact that you're vulnerable. That's a form of courage.
That's not a form of weakness,
but that leads you to take whatever steps are necessary to deal with that
properly. It isn't some facade that you're invulnerable.
No one is invulnerable by any stretch of the imagination and to stand up and
face. That is, is the best route that you have.
Why, why do you think so many young men are following you because you,
you have a lot of years.
The best for them genuinely that I'm encouraging more than
you do for young women. No, no, not, it's not.
The way you think so many are young men.
Oh, well I think part of it's technological fluke. I mean,
I came to prominence at least in part on YouTube because I put my university
lectures there and it happens to be the case that 80% of the people who watch
YouTube are young men. So there's that,
and it's hard to know how to factor that in exactly. But then I'm also,
I think that young women are encouraged a lot,
which is fine as far as I'm concerned.
But I think that that's less true for young men now because we
believe that there's something pernicious about male competence and
activity. It's part of a,
I suppose it's part of the notion that the best way to characterize Western
society is as a tyrannical patriarchy, which is appalling doctrine,
as far as I'm concerned, how come is that? Well,
it's not a tyrannical patriarchy, so it's not tyrannical.
That's the first thing.
Certainly not compared to any other governmental form that currently
exists and has ever existed.
And it's not essentially patriarchal unless you believe that women haven't
contributed in immense part to the construction of what we have now.
So,
and I also don't believe that to the degree that it is patriarchal,
that its structure is dependent on the expression of power,
arbitrary power on the part of men. I think that happens sometimes,
but only when things go wrong.
What you're doing and doing now as well is, is,
is challenging. The,
the idea of gender equality that is very important in, in, in,
um, in Scandinavia. I think it's it's, as you probably know, um,
w why, why do you think that that can be a problem?
The idea of gender equality?
I don't think that equality of opportunity is a problem.
I think that's a great thing. And anyone with any sense champions,
equality of opportunity. I mean,
even if you're purely selfish say and purely self-centered,
you'd want to set up an economy where everyone who had ability could be
maximally exploited by everyone else,
because then we can all benefit from each other's talents.
And so equality of opportunity is absolutely useful fundamental
principle, but that has nothing to do with equality of outcome.
Those things aren't even in the same conceptual universe and to strive for
equality of outcome is well,
it's a fool's game and likely to be extraordinarily,
it has proved to be in the past extraordinarily dangerous,
as well as impossible. So, I mean,
one of the things we know for example is that I don't know to what degree it's
common knowledge in Scandinavia,
but the biggest differences between men and women in the world in
terms of temperament and interests are in Scandinavia.
And they've maximized as a consequence of the, your egalitarian policies.
What do you mean by that? It means that the more he galitary in your state,
the bigger, the personality differences between men and women,
that's like the it's.
How do you measure that? How do you know that? Oh.
Well, psychologists have perfected at least to some degree,
the measure of personality over the last 30 years with very advanced statistical
models. And so what you do is you offer men and women,
well validated tests of preference and of personality.
And you do that all across the world with tens of thousands of people in
multi-country samples.
And then you look at the difference between men and women,
and then you rank order that by wealth and egalitarian social policy,
and what you find is the more egalitarian this society,
the more different the men and women become.
Is there something you can recognize or is it.
I would say for me, it's quite the simple question actually,
do we want that our sons and daughters should have the same
opportunities and, uh, eh, the same MAB, eh,
the same dreams or hopes for the good thing or no?
And for me, it's simple to ask the answer that it's yes, of course. So for me,
equality and gender equality is very, very important for me. Also,
when we talk about gender equality is important for me to learn my daughter,
that her mom, uh,
can lead and show the way and her dad can hug and kiss her
and show feelings. And I think that's something very important for the,
the hoods where kids grew up to show feelings to,
to have these gender equality discussions,
to show her a way of opportunities and to strive forward.
And it's important both for, uh,
lonely men and lonely young men,
but also for women that feel this,
this roof of gloss, uh,
they need to fight them to struggle the roof of glass to
yeah. To be successful in their lives.
Do you agree on this?
I think that equality of opportunity is a perfectly reasonable proposition.
I mean, I have a daughter and a wife, I do everything. I bought many,
many female clients who I've consulted with and helped. And,
and in many cases, uh, accelerated,
helped accelerate the development of their career tremendously.
It's of obviously of great utility to encourage forward
striving in,
in young people and people in general that that's not the issue in the least,
but the issue is the outcome. Yeah. Well then why do you think, eh, the,
the outcome on these countries where they outcome is as is more equal,
why do you think that leads to a bigger differences? Oh,
because there's only two reasons that men and women different.
One is cultural and the other is biological.
And if you minimize the cultural differences,
you maximize the biological differences.
So I know everyone's shocked when they hear this, this isn't shocking news.
People have known this in the scientific community for at least 25 years.
And it's been replicated in the last month,
three times in three separate samples, including in science,
which is the world's greatest scientific magazine by a large margin.
And it isn't a small effect. It's a huge effect.
Excuse me, what does it mean?
Does it mean that Scandinavian men and women are having more difficulties
meeting each other, talking to each other than others?
No, not necessarily,
but it does mean that there are reasons for differences in participation
rates, in different occupations, that aren't a consequence of socialization.
So for example, as this especially true at the extreme. So for example, um,
on average,
men are more interested in things and women are more interested in people.
And that's actually the biggest difference we know of psychologically between
men and women. And,
and even though men and women are quite similar,
all things considered the extremes make a difference.
So you imagine that in order to become an engineer, look,
obviously not everyone becomes an engineer.
You have to have a particular temperamental proclivity to become an engineer.
You have to be extraordinarily interested in things rather than people,
while most of those people are men. And if you want to become a nurse, well,
then you have to be much more interested in people than you are in things.
And most of those people are women.
And so you get differences in occupational choice that are also by the way,
quite great in Scandinavia,
especially in the case of engineering and nursing that are mostly due to
biological differences. And you cannot minimize that by social engineering.
So, and that is not a bad thing.
Like look of the things you want to ask yourself is that what is the purpose of
setting up a society that offers maximal equality of opportunity?
And one of the answers is that you maximize people's free choice.
And if you maximize free choice,
then you also maximize differences in choice between people.
And so you can't have both of those, but of course it will have.
Have differences is in short is of course, because we are human beings,
but I can't see why it differs between
me and [inaudible] for instance.
But of course it differs in biological things,
but not in choices because I think more how we raise
them, uh,
how we'll live education sort of culture
attitudes, form a human being,
whether or not they are a girl or a boy when they grow up.
And if I raise my daughter to become a leader,
to be self-confident to have a high education,
for instance, I think she will have a good platform to become an civil engineer,
to become a CEO of a company or to become a nurse.
Oh, that, that is what, that is.
What people who think that the differences between people who are primarily
culturally constructed believe, but it's not what the evidence suggests.
Okay. You don't check
[inaudible].
To understand about this is this.
This is not a contentious issue among informed scientists.
We've known this for 25 years. And so, and it's a perverse effect.
No one expected it.
Why, why do you talk then about you talk about chaos. Um,
I mean, is, is what we're experiencing now, chaos, your book is,
is called an antidote to chaos. What is the cows?
Well,
I think the chaos is the uncertainty that so many people feel about the meaning
of life and about their position in the world.
That that's fundamentally what I was aiming at and what I'm trying to do in my
online lectures.
And with my book is to provide people with a guideline to meaning.
So one of the points that I make in my lectures for example,
is that we actually have a biological instinct for meaning that orients us in
the world.
And that instinct manifests itself when we
place ourselves in a position in the world where we're competent,
where what we're doing is working so that we're not too terrified and
anxious,
but also while we're simultaneously advancing ourselves and improving our
ability to cope with the world. So for example, if you watch an athlete,
high-level athlete, who's at the peak of his or her performance,
you see someone who's extraordinarily practiced at what they're doing and has
developed the expertise necessary to do it,
but then you also see them push themselves on that developmental edge to make
themselves just that much better. And that,
that function is associated with an intrinsic sense of meaning.
And whenever you see anyone manifest that you,
you are automatically drawn to it, you,
you see that when an actor pushes him or herself beyond their limits,
you see that when someone speaks extemporaneously and manages it extraordinarily
well, and I'm trying to help people understand that this,
this meaning is a true phenomenon. It's not a secondary thing.
And also to point out that most of the time,
that meaning is associated with the adoption of responsibility.
So this is also something that people don't understand.
But, but, but part of the kales is that the rules are so hard to see the, the,
the, the, there aren't that obvious rules anymore.
The chaos is that we we're transforming our landscape socially,
culturally,
technologically so rapidly that it's hard for people to gain footing.
And so it destabilizes us.
This isn't the real problem. That's
quite a lot of men.
And also young men are struggling to deal with the fact that women now
are more in control of their lives than earlier.
I don't think that's the problem.
I think the problem is is that the idea that the West
is a patriarchal tyranny is rapidly translated into the idea that
young men who strive forward or to be regarded with suspicion because they're
doing nothing but manifesting the same sort of tyrannical power that has kept
women are oppressed for the last 2000 years.
And I think that entire narrative is appalling right to the core. So,
and I don't see that it's helpful to anyone because making young men weak or,
or a law or, or failing to encourage them to be strong,
that's a better way of putting it certainly does the young men. No. Good.
And it doesn't do the young women any good at all,
if they want to find a partner.
So you're saying that all along,
we may have had the same opportunities, always.
No, I'm basically saying that all along hardly anyone had any opportunities.
I mean, if you look at the history of the world, um,
things really started to shift in about 1895,
but before 1895,
the typical person in the West lived on less than a dollar a day in today's
money, which is about two thirds,
the UN cutoff for abject poverty by today's standards.
And so what happened through most of the history of the world is that men and
women struggled mightily together sometimes at each other's throats,
but mostly cooperatively to keep the Wolf from the door.
And the tyrant have Bay life was very, very, very, very difficult.
And the fact that we survived at all meant that fundamentally we cooperated
despite the fact that were rife with stupidity ignorance and malevolence,
but what's.
Terrifying with gender equality.
Nothing here is except when people gerrymandered the data. It's like,
what do you mean by equality?
Do you want women to have their free choice or not? If you do,
they're not going to pick occupations that are the same as the occupations men.
But we have structures today that that women need to struggle. They need to,
to, uh, take a step, uh, to,
to have the possibility to become like a prime minister. As we talked before,
we don't have had any prime minister in Sweden that had been a woman,
for instance, uh,
we have a lower rate of female entrepreneurs.
Uh, men had that higher income than women, uh, in Sweden.
Uh, even if they work with the same, uh, tasks and they need the work,
which one that I need to work with gender equality,
I think even in the lower class in schools to learn kids how
to play with dolls,
[inaudible] we need to, I think we need to learn boys to be more sensitive,
but also young girls to become more self-confident.
And I think that's very important too.
Well, the problem with that,
the problem with that is the data indicate that the consequence of the policies
that you're promoting have maximized the differences between men and women.
So that isn't what it's doing now that isn't to say that the movement
towards egalitarianism is necessarily a bad thing,
but tremendous amount of that's being driven, not by social policy,
but by technology. I mean, you know,
the narrative that we're fed now is that up until 1960,
when the enlightened feminists developed their egalitarian doctrines,
men had kept women down and they finally Rose.
And the truth of the matter is, is that from about nine, 1895 onward,
there was a series of technological revolutions that were extraordinarily
powerful in their impact that allowed women to step forward free of
many of the burdens that had kept them back in the past birth control being one
of them, but only, only, only one
sanitary facilities of all sorts plumbing had a huge role to play.
Tampons had a huge role to play as did sanitary napkins.
All of these technologies developed that enabled women to, uh, to, to,
to move forward, to move forward with, with,
with less biological impediments, let's say.
What would you say is the best period in history to be both a man and a woman.
Clearly now there's no, absolutely no doubt about that.
Anyone who would like to worry for the kales, you worry about the kales.
You know, it's nice if we could make things better than they are.
And I would say that just as all around the world,
we're raising living standards at a rate that is absolutely unparalleled in
human history. We're also in danger of destabilizing our culture in the West.
And I don't think that part of that problem you called, uh,
you talk about there is what we call the identity. Yes.
I think that any O any political position that puts someone's group identity
ahead of their individuality is a regression to a kind of a regression
to a tribalism that will definitely become violent because that's what happens
to try.
What's an example.
Of identity politics playing that role. What happens every time people divide,
divide themselves into tribal groups. I mean,
what we're trying to do to make peace is to bring people under the rubric of
something, approximating a single identity, a shared identity. And I mean,
the evidence that people fight in tribes, it's the,
that's the entire evidence of the human race.
And the farther back you go in time and the smaller,
the tribal groups become the higher,
the rates of inter tribal warfare and the higher the rates of homicide.
And, and, and this you're talking about, there's this,
I think it's part of why you also are people feel some kind of ambivalence
towards, towards you also. I mean, we call it controversial from time to time.
And, um, I don't know. Do you like that being controversial? Do you enjoy, uh,
provoking groups? Like.
No, and I don't provoke people. I just say what I think.
I just see what you believe to be true. Well, that's no, I don't. I say,
I say what I believe to be true and people find that provoking.
That's not the same as me provoking people. If I was provoking people,
I would be setting out to upset them and I'm not setting out to upset them.
I'm just setting out to say what I believe to be true. And I'm a very, you're.
Following the, the, the rules. We talked.
About this. And when I'm talking about gender, gender issues, for example,
in personality, that's actually one of my fields of expertise.
I know the literature and it says exactly what I said. It says. And as I said,
as well, it's been replicated three times in the last month.
The London times came out three weeks ago and said that the finding that
gender differences maximize as he galitary and policies are developed is now one
of the most solidly grounded findings ever produced by social scientists.
So, you know, you can make of that, what you want.
It's not something that I particularly enjoy. It just happens to be the case.
Sorry, the fake news about John Pittson.
Oh, well, the, the fake news is one is that I'm provocative.
The other is that the other is that I have a,
like a right leaning or a particularly conservative agenda.
And the mere fact that I oppose radical left.
You're a conservative at heart, aren't you?
Not particularly, um, I don't have the temperament for it. So for example,
our conservative people tend to be low in trait, openness,
which is associated with creativity. And I am very high in trade openness.
And so temperamentally, I'm not much of a conservative at all.
And people who knew me,
people who come to my house would certainly not think that I was a conservative
person. So, or, or if they, they saw the breadth of my ideas,
I'm also very entrepreneurially minded, which also is not with conservatism.
Um, I am a great skeptic of well-meaning attempts to
adjust large social systems on the basis of ideology,
but that doesn't make me conservative.
It just makes me educated social scientists.
So w w when,
when are you provoked herself?
Um, when am I provoked myself? Oh, being called a Nazi.
I find somewhat provoking that I think one of the most observed days. No,
no, certainly not one of the most absurd days in my life, in the last two years.
And there's been plenty of them was a day,
probably three months ago where I was accused by one magazine in the UK of being
a Jewish shill and another magazine in the United States of being an alt-right
Nazi. I thought, well, that's, that's it,
I pretty much covered both ends of the insults. It's like, yeah, that's right.
So you can average that out to zero, I suppose. So, um,
I find, I find that somewhat provoking, um,
but you know, you take the good with the bad and, and I I'm,
I'm not, I'm not complaining about it. It's funny. It is.
Is, is it, is it true that you have an opinion about,
about people, uh,
having to stay married if they have children? I mean, men here,
it's better if they do it's. I think most people would,
would agree that that's the best bit, but yeah, as far as I understand you,
you think that the laws should say that we have to stay together.
It isn't obvious to me that the liberalization of the divorce laws in the
sixties was for everyone's best interest now. Exactly what that means.
I'm not sure. I mean,
it's okay for people to go to hell in hand in hand basket in their own
particular means of choosing. But we do know that stable, intact,
two parent families are better for children. So, you know,
it depends on who you put first. And look,
I'm not saying that everyone who's got divorced is reprehensible.
I understand that life is very difficult and that it's a very hard thing to
maintain a relationship over a very long period of time,
but it's not obvious to me that we're better off for the additional plethora of
choices. So.
We'll see.
But there isn't that an individual choice and not something the law should
decide.
Well, it depends to some degree on whether the law should advocate for children.
I mean, children really can't speak for themselves. Can they,
they need some authority to speak for them. And so we do know like the data,
for example, on,
on child welfare indicates Krista it's crystal clear that
children from intact two-parent families do better on virtually every measure
that you can possibly imagine. So what are we supposed to make of that?
It's irrelevant. She's like maybe the rule should be, if,
if you don't have children, then no problem divorce is no problem.
If you have children and plus it's not like divorce solves the problem with
regards to, to, to your relationship with your ex,
it often produces a whole boatload of problems that you didn't expect. So,
but I'm not advocating draconian measures to keep people together who don't want
to be together. That that horse has already left the barn.
Age, limit on the children where you can divorce or, well, the older,
the older the children are the less effect it has on them. So, you know, and
the alleged for divorce, yes. 45,
something like that. I don't know. I don't know what the,
I don't know what the ideal age. What about, what about when you were,
when you were a kid yourself? Who, who was your, uh, masculine role model?
Oh, I think I had a number of them,
but it would probably primarily have been my father and some of my friends
because peers play an important role in, in development,
especially after a year after the age of about four,
but I would definitely say it was my father.
And how would you describe his masculinity? Well, he, to your point, um,
he spent a tremendous amount of time with me when I was a kid.
And they're very fond memories as far as I'm concerned. Like when,
when I was a young, when I was very young, two and three,
my dad would come home from work and he spent an hour and a half with me at
night for, for a long time teaching me to read,
which has been in estimate benefit with me. And he did many things with me,
you know, we hunted and trapped and canoed and fished and CA and, and,
um, he was a harsh guy in many ways. He was a disciplinary and in some sense,
um, but,
but he was very honest and very good craftsman. And, uh,
and so I learned a lot about, um,
trying to conduct yourself in a respectable manner from him. So.
Were you a, a tough kid or were you a Kanthal kid or what kind of kid were you?
Hi, I guess it depends on what you mean by tough. No,
I don't think if you would have met me when I was a kid,
you would've thought I was tough. I'm kind of a tender hearted character. And,
um, and I was skipped a grade and I was small for my age. And so,
um, I certainly wasn't physically tough in the standard sense,
um, because I was small and because I'd been put ahead of grade, I was never,
um, particularly fast style at sports. And that was kind of a problem.
I did something about that when I got older, but, um,
I hung around with tough kids,
but that was partly because most of the kids that were in the
town I grew up in were,
were either tough kids or were sort of off the radar entirely. And so,
and maybe that was a certain amount of compensation.
I could defend myself verbally fairly well. So,
but that tended to get me hung up by my, you know,
my shirt color in closets and played catch with on the stairs and that sort of
thing in junior high. So, um.
Is it, is it like, uh,
do you come from an environment where, where,
where we can as was a bad thing where self-pitying was a bad thing.
Um, where self-pitying was a bad thing? I would say, yes,
I come from that background, but that was, that was par for the course,
I would say when I grew up and I mean, where, where I grew up,
it was still a frontier place. In some sense, you know,
my town was only 50 years old and people were essentially
self-reliant to the degree that that was possible.
It was certainly the case within my family, on both my mother and father's side.
And the idea was, but this wasn't particularly,
what would you say unique to my family? You know, they, ethos was
feeling sorry for yourself. Isn't going to be of much utility.
You should get out there and do what you can do and straighten your back.
Yes. If you can do that.
And I got lots of encouragement from my parents from both of them. Um,
certainly I've a very good relationship with my mother who I loved very much.
And we, we shared a sense of humor, which was lovely. And my dad,
although he was a harsh taskmaster, um,
also was very encouraging to me in that he believed that
I could do whatever I put my mind to.
And he helped instill that conviction in me in a manner that I hope
wasn't and isn't too, um,
let's say narcissistic, it wasn't a matter of privilege.
It was a matter of drive and dedication and effort.
And so that was one of the things that's so sad about what I'm doing.
You know, I'm going all around the world and I'm talking to many,
many people I've talked to about 250,000 people in the last six months.
And I offer encouraging words. You know, that people,
I believe that people are stronger than their misfortunes.
I believe that if you turn around and confront the vulnerability,
that's part and parcel of life,
you'll find within yourself a strength that will transcend that. And I,
I believe that not only to be true,
but supported by the best clinical evidence and that it's important for lost
young people, male and female alike,
to develop a vision and take on some responsibility and understand
that they have a vital role to play in the world, that.
The lack of their best hurts day.
I think that's true. And the sad thing is that very.
There's very many people who have not.
Heard an encouraging word in their life, and.
It takes so little to encourage them.
It's rather tragic. You know, I have people come up to me and I mean all,
and by all the time, I mean many people every day.
In the lectures and on the street who tell me, I was in a bad place.
I was struggling. I've been watching your lectures.
I've been reading your book. I put my life together.
I'm trying to be responsible. Tell the truth.
Things are way better. Thank you. And so that's,
can't, can't get any better than that. So, and that's.
[Inaudible] back to the divorce.
Question.
What is the best situation to tell your children?
We don't love each other anymore,
but we're going to stay together for your sake so that you will have assemblance
of a happy family life or to say, I'm sorry,
this doesn't work. We'll, we'll continue to love you, but we'll part,
and we'll love you the rest of our lives.
And maybe we even can be happy on, on our different.
Well, sometimes, sometimes,
often you have to make the best of a bad lot. You know? I mean,
sometimes the best possible choice isn't there in front of you. And I would say,
well,
it's generally up to each person to decide under the
circumstances,
which of those pathways forward would be likely to cause the least amount of
misery for, well, you know, for you, for your wife, for your kids,
you know, you have to balance all of that out. That's not an easy thing to do.
Um, I would also say that by the time it comes to the point where you're
divorced divorcing, um,
all you may have left or one of two suboptimal choices. And you know,
so part of what I do as well is to try to lecture about what sort of
interactions might facilitate a marriage,
such that it's less likely to end up in a situation like that. Now,
sometimes people have irreconcilable differences and there's nothing that can be
done about it. But often people are not good at negotiating,
partly because they don't, they won't admit what they want,
because then they know that then they know if they're not getting it,
they make their criteria for failure clear, and that frightens them.
So they keep themselves vague because they don't know what they want.
They can't communicate it to their partners.
And they don't know how to do that anyways,
because they're not very good at negotiating and then they avoid conflict.
And so then the conflict, because when you avoid conflict,
all you do is store it up for the future. And, you know,
I've seen lots of people on the brink of divorce and in horrible marital
situations, horrible family situations. And, you know,
they have 25,000 disputes that haven't been settled.
And at that point it's like,
maybe divorce is the best option,
but that doesn't mean that it was the best option from the beginning.
So hopefully people can learn to negotiate and to tell each other the,
and that will increase.
The probability that they can maintain their relationships in a stable manner.
But, and I'm not sure.
I'm not suggesting by the way that you didn't do that because I don't know
anything about your situation.
No. So I'm a little bit surprised that you don't take into account
our level of irrationality or super irrational people when you
discuss.
It's like we can all just agree on these things and look at the science and the
real fix everything. That's not how we vote. No,
I don't think people are rational at all.
And I think that it's very difficult for us to negotiate and it's amazing that
we ever live in peace.
Yeah. It's tremendously difficult. So one last question. When,
when are you irrational?
When I'm hungry, what happens then? Um,
little things bother.
Me far more than they would bother any reasonable.
Person. So that's,
and I would say if you find that you're irrational like that frequently,
one of the things you might try is to eat something.
And you, and you have a, you have a peculiar diet. You have a, you have,
you could say that again. Yes. What, what, what is it, what what's the, well,
there seems to be some sort of.
Auto-immune condition in my family and some of it's also reflected in my wife's
family, unfortunately.
And the culmination of that was that my daughter had an extraordinarily serious,
serious set of auto-immune dysfunctions that caused her
an endless amount of misery and destruction.
And she found out about three years ago as a consequence of very,
very careful experimentation that if she ate nothing but
meat, then all her symptoms disappeared. So,
and her primary symptoms were degenerative bone disease that had been diagnosed
as idiopathic arthritis, which means arthritis with no known cause.
And she had her ankle and her hip replaced when she was in her teens because of
that and had 38 other effective affected joints. So it was hell.
And, um,
she caught onto the fact that diet had something to do with it for a variety of
reasons. I can't go into and,
and radically restricted her eating and all her symptoms disappeared.
So that is why the, you do it as well. Yes. Well, I had many,
but not all of the same symptoms. And she told,
I watched what happened to her and I thought, well,
that's impossible because it was,
and she encouraged me to try it and I thought, well,
I can try anything for a month. You know? And so I,
I started for a month and I had changes almost immediately. And so,
um, I've continued with a very restricted diet for about two years and
extraordinarily restricted for the last eight months. So,
and that seems to be working for me quite well, even though it's,
you know, it has its downsides. Uh,
Jordan Peterson has been so interesting talking to you. Thank you so much.
Thanks.
You very much.
[inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations.
Please hit subscribe.